What's up everyone! Today we're learning English
with the Disney animation Tangled. now Tangled
tells the classic story of Rapunzel and this movie
actually just celebrated its 10th anniversary.
By watching this lesson you'll learn vocabulary
related to daily routines and free time activities
with one of the famous songs of the movie. You'll
also learn conversational expressions with a
message from Mandy Moore and Zach Levi who voiced
the main characters. But before we get into it
and in case you're new here I want to let you know
that every week we make lessons just like this one
to help you learn fast English, without getting,
lost without missing the jokes and without
subtitles. Just like Faustina who says that
watching our lessons is a pleasure. So be sure to
hit that subscribe button and the bell down below
so that you don't miss any of our new lessons.
How did it go? If you'd like to learn
more about real native pronunciation
then I highly recommend our Fluent with
Friends Course. You can try it right now
for free with our Three-Part Masterclass!
All you have to do is click up here or down
in the description box below to learn more
and sign up now. I highly recommend it.